so what comes in your mind when we say
the word puny now if you're like me then
and you're a Star Wars fan then you
might know that clone troopers are one
of the biggest armies in Star Wars right
so clone troopers are looking alike
armies so something which look alike is
called as clones right exactly similar
in terms of DNA
what does cloning means or what is a DNA
clone definitely DNA clone means similar
looking DNA or similar DNA in terms of
characteristics and properties so
cloning a DNA is pretty much comparable
to a copying machine which copies paper
right so just like we have to give paper
into a copying machine we have to give
our DNA to a machine and the machine is
bacteria right now in a copying machine
we have to give that paper which it
copies and give us multiple copies now
we have to put our gene of interest in a
specific format which is understandable
by the bacteria such that it can also
take the our input or take our input DNA
and make multiple copies of it now how
many copies that they would make it
depends upon the bacteria because some
bacteria like to make a lot of copies of
the DNA some bacteria like less but the
added advantage with using a bacteria is
the bacteria itself if given proper
temperature and proper media then
bacteria grows quite fast right and as
they grow the gene of interest or the
DNA of interest that we are looking at
that also grow in number so definitely
let's just don't waste our time and
energy let's just quickly jump into the
metal metal cloning can be achieved the
first step is choosing a particular
vector the vector is
just a media by which it can take our
gene of interest inside the bacteria
most of the cases these are plasmids so
first step plasmid has to be digested
with proper restriction enzymes and then
there is the digested plasmid should be
purified and cleaned up then comes our
gene of interest the gene of interest
has to be cleaved with the same
restriction enzyme with which we are
cleaving the plasmid and digestion with
proper restriction enzyme is important
for proper cloning and followed by the
digestion you should clean the digested
product now important step is ligation
in this step T for T in a ligase is
important and the ligation efficiency
depends upon vector to insert ratio
incubation time and incubation
temperature of course once it is ligated
and we get a proof of that ligation then
we can insert the plasmid along with our
gene of interest inside the bacteria by
a process known as transformation by
giving them a heat shock and the
bacteria would eat up the plasmid right
now after the bacteria has eaten up the
plasmid now we just need the bacteria to
grow so we give bacteria a proper
Culture Media where it can grow in
number and once the bacteria grows our
gene of interest which is inside the
plasmid also grows and then we can
isolate the plasmid and take out our
gene of interest but the problem here is
twofold first of all some bacteria might
eat up the plasmid some bacteria might
not so how would you ensure ensure that
in the culture which bacteria has your
gene of interest so we need some
selectable markers or some resistance
markers by which we can like clearly
kill those bacterias which don't have
the plus plasmid right so that is why we
put antibiotic resistance gene which
works like a selectable
so if we give antibiotics into the
Culture Media now only those bacteria
would survive which has the
antibacterial gene inside it right so
that means the bacteria which has eaten
the plasmid up would only survive and
the others would just die right that is
why we can get rid of those bacterias
which hasn't eaten up or has not been
transformed with the plasmid now here
comes the second problem now from the
ligated product there could be some some
plasmids which are self rioted don't
have been stood insert and some plasmid
which has the insert now we want the
plasmid which has insert that means our
gene of interest so how do we get rid of
the second one so in order to get rid of
the self ligated palce plasmid we can
use selectable marker so screen herbal
markers so most of the cases plasmid has
screw nobel markers such as the gene
that codes for lag c a lag c produce
beta galactosidase and as we know beta
galactosidase
break down vinegar galactose it is it
makes glucose to lactose right so
lactose to glucose now beta
galactosidase can cleave a product color
product known as x cal to give a blue
colored product right now if we if the
gene is active then beta galactosidase
would be produced and the bacterial
colony would produce beta galactosidase
and thereby adding the substrate on the
media would produce blue colored
colonies on the other hand side if
Pyrrhic electricity is is somehow not
produced because the gene is somehow
disrupted because insertion of the gene
of interest then be a galactosidase
won't be produced as a result if now the
bacteria is
in transformed with the plasmid
containing gene of interest it would
give rise to colonies but the colonies
would be colorless upon adding eggs gal
so we know the colonies which are white
in color have our gene of interest the
blue ones doesn't have that on basis of
that we can clearly understand that the
blue color colonies are of no use the
white color colonies have our
recombinant DNA so we can screen among
these two situations as well and then we
can take out the white color colonies
and culture them and make a pure culture
out of it now once we culture it in a
bulk situation we can pull down the
bacterial cells take out the DNA now
that DNA is simply from several
bacterias we can isolate the plasmid DNA
and now the plasmid DNA has many many
copies of our gene of interest so we can
store that for future use now the
question is what is the use of this
recombinant DNA so the recombinant DNA
or the cloned DNA could have several use
like making transgenic animals making
transgenic plants making transgenic
synthetic proteins or chimeras protein
or several other genetic engineering
applications which we would be talking
in subsequent videos but for now if you
liked my video give it a quick thumbs up
and don't like to like share and
subscribe and do let me know in the
comment section if you have a specific
questions or how do you like my video
thank